Hello students, welcome
to the Pharmacology
of the Immunosuppressant Drugs.
This is a lecture in two parts.
It is going to be describing
this pharmacology,
immunosuppression,
immunosuppressive agents,
in the context of
transplantation pharmacology.
In this context, you will
be able to use the knowledge
you learned here and apply
it to immunosuppressive
therapy for the autoimmune
and inflammatory diseases
as well. The concepts
are readily transferable.
Please contact me if you'd like
to talk about pharmacology.
Here are the learning
objectives, pharmacokinetic
properties, mechanisms,
mechanisms, mechanisms, and this
includes mechanisms of the
adverse effects and drug
interactions as always.
And I challenge you to make
yourself some sort of a
scheme, whether it's a concept
map, mind map, something,
in order to help you
integrate concepts with each
other. and bridge them to
the clinical aspects of
transplantation therapy, which
you will be able to apply
when you are treating your
patients for inflammatory
or autoimmune conditions.
the preparation materials
as always the practice
questions are all that I
personally require they
will help you to be able
to integrate and bridge
concepts here are the links
if you wish to use them.
Key points. I'm going to
read this slide to you.
Knowledge of the biologic
function of T and B
lymphocytes is essential
for understanding the
pharmacology of the
immunosuppressive agents
and immunomodulation
in general.
We will be focusing
on the mechanisms
of action, adverse effects,
in solid organ allograft
rejection, acute
organ rejection.
The basic principles
of immunosuppressants
in this context can
be applied to their
application for autoimmune
and inflammatory
diseases and also graft
-versus-host disease.
I will not be spending time
on that particular aspect.
The pharmacology of drugs
that enhance the immune
system, the other half of
the immunomodulator concept,
will not be addressed
in this lecture.
This is a scheme of the
cellular interactions.
I have it here to
introduce you to
the concepts of acute
organ rejection and
the rationale for
the way it's treated.
here's our cd4 cell and it's
the cd4 positive t cells
that are central to the
cascade of events that lead
to allograft rejection what
i want to point out here
is The idea of the antigen
-presenting cell in contact
with the T-lymphocyte,
activation of the T
-lymphocyte, the importance of
interleukin-2 in the cascade
of reactions that will
recruit the effector cells,
and the responses.
Here we have our CD8
cell, our activated
cytotoxic T cell, and these are
what attack, appear
to be so anyway,
attack and cause rejection
of the allograft. Of
course, everything else
gets to be involved as
well. and we'll be also
addressing B lymphocytes.
This is a close-up of
that interaction between
the antigen-presenting
cell and the T cell.
What we don't see
here is our CD. CD, so
this will be our CD4
or CD8 connection.
Here's MHC, could
be MHC 1 or 2.
Our T-cell receptor with
the antigen presentation.
We will be talking
about this aspect,
which is the co
-stimulatory aspect.
So antigen is presented
to the T-cell via
the MHC, and there is
a co-stimulator action
in order to bring that
T-cell to activation.
And CTLA-4 is an
inhibitory action i'll talk
more about that when we
get there to this the
draw to the drug that
reflects this action
here are key points
i will not be reading
this to you talking
about the drugs
and let us begin commonly
transplanted organs are
kidney liver heart lungs
pancreas and intestines
Organ transplantation
began with the
transplant of a kidney
between identical twins.
Identical twins are identical
and immunosuppression
therapy is not needed. With
the advent of effective
immunosuppressants, it
was possible to transplant
kidneys from non-genetically
identical individuals.
These are called allografts.
It all started with the kidney.
And since then, because
of the understanding
of transplant immunosuppression
and the advent
of excellent drugs, the
organ transplantations
have been extended to
these other organs.
Immunosuppressive
drugs dampen the immune
response. Combinations
of drugs, key point here,
blocking different targets
in the immune cascade may
allow lower doses to maintain
adequate immunosuppression.
And what have we been
talking about since
the beginning of your
understanding of pharmacology?
And that is to minimize
adverse events,
which are almost
always, not always,
dose-related.
So if we can lower the
doses, we can possibly
reduce, or at least
limit, the degree
of adverse effects.
So that's the concept.
Not everybody can have
their doses lowered.
It depends on the patient,
depends on the graft,
depends on the match
of the tissues.
Why do we have
transplantation? Because it
improves long-term
survival and the quality of
life for many patients
who have organ failure.
Allograft rejection,
the definition is the
recipient's immune system
attacks the foreign
antigens in the allograft.
That's what our immune
system does. It attacks
foreign antigens.
Graft versus host disease
occurs when immunologically
competent immune cells
in the allograft that's
transplanted into an
immunodeficient recipient
recognize the recipient's
antigens as foreign
and attack it.
So the recipient's
tissues are attacked
by the immune cells in the
grafted tissue from the donor.
Graft versus host disease
is a common complication
of stem cell
transplant. It can occur
if the solid organ that's
transplanted is rich
in immunologically
competent immune cells.
Types of rejection.
Hyperacute rejection.
This occurs nearly
immediately because
the host already has
preformed antibodies.
against these foreign
antigens from the
tissue that's transplanted.
And so they'll
just attack, and
they cause necrosis.
And to this point,
immunosuppressant drugs are
not able to stop
hyperacute rejection. It's
very important to be
able to identify that the
graft is going to be
successful in advance.
Acute rejection, this is
what we will be talking
about in terms of trying to
prevent, occurs usually in
days to weeks. It can be
cellular T-cell related or
humoral antibody related
or both. acute rejection
results from the expression
of hla class 1 and hla
class 2 antigens in the
allograft with early infiltration
of cd8 t cells this is
these are the cytotoxic
t lymphocytes and these
are seen on histopathology.
CD4T cells are the maestro, as
we saw in that earlier slide.
Importantly, a single
episode of acute rejection
that is promptly diagnosed
and treated It often prevents
the organ or tissue
failure, and success is,
the outcomes of it have a
very high rate of success.
Recurrence of acute rejection,
this can lead to chronic
rejection, and this is a
very unfortunate event.
It occurs gradually,
gradually over years, and it
leads to the fibrosis and
loss of the graft function.
And we are trying to
prevent chronic rejection by
preventing acute rejection,
but it can still occur.
This is just a little
overview of the various
targets of immunosuppressant
therapies, and we will
be seeing that several
of the transplantation
immunosuppressive drugs
actually fall into these
categories. I'll let you have
a look at this on your own
time. I think you will
find it helpful to give
yourself the big picture
of how immunosuppressants
work, their targets, their
mechanisms of action.
So we're going to look
more closely at the
intracellular, very
simplistic picture of
the intracellular
pathways related to the
drugs for transplantation
immunosuppression.
We'll be talking about the
calcineurin inhibitors.
Why are they called
calcineurin inhibitors?
Because they inhibit
calcineurin. which is a
calcium-dependent molecule
that activates something
called nuclear factor
of activated T cells,
NFAT, NFAT, nuclear factor
of activated T cells.
And this will trigger
transcription of cytokines.
Thinking about IL-2 here.
IL-2 is a cytokine
that has autocrine
functions and also
paracrine functions. It will
activate IL-2 receptors
on its neighbors.
We will be looking at drugs
in the cytokine pathway.
We will be blocking the
activity of mTOR, which is a
kinase, And that will bring
proliferation to a halt.
We will be talking about
a drug that blocks the
receptor and prevents
interleukin-2 from binding.
We will be talking
about drugs that
act here, directly
on DNA synthesis.
and bring the cell
cycle to a halt.
And we will be
talking about this
drug, the anti-CD52 antibody.
And let us not forget
the co-stimulatory
signal that is
inhibited by this drug.
signal one this is our
t-cell receptor which is
a complex between t-cell
receptor and cd3 this
drug is off the market
because of adverse effects
and better drugs came
along but there is an
anti-cd3 drug that's been
marketed for the treatment
of diabetes mellitus
type one early stages.
Immunosuppression in organ
transplant, allograft
transplant, is divided into
induction therapy and maintenance
therapy. On these two slides,
I've given you the big
overview of these drugs. If
you know these mechanisms
and effects, you basically will
understand immunosuppressive
therapy related to
allograft transplantation.
So induction therapy, we'll be
talking about
antithymocyte globulin,
we'll be talking about the
IL-2 alpha chain inhibitor,
in other words the drug
that blocks IL-2 receptor.
This would be an R in here,
IL-2 receptor alpha chain.
and a CD52 inhibitor. These
are induction therapy.
Why? Because two of them
cause profound T-cell
depletion. We're removing
the T-cells from circulation.
Therefore, they're not
available to attack the graft.
And we have one that's
referred to as a
non-depleting agent.
We'll see why when we
get to the pharmacology
of basilexamab.
The maintenance therapy
drugs are combinations
of these various
maintenance therapies.
The most common combination
is among these three classes,
calcinarin inhibitors,
antimetabolites,
and glucocorticoids. And
of them, the preferred
drugs are tacrolimus,
also pronounced
tacrolimus, I'll
pronounce it tacrolimus,
mycophenolate mofetil,
and oral prednisone.
this lecture will also
talk about glucocorticoids
that will be the
transition stage because
methylprednisolone is
also used in induction
therapy and we know that
prednisone is used in
maintenance therapy the
next lecture will talk
about all of these.
Now these drugs used
for induction are also
used for established
acute allograft rejection
to interfere with that
inflammatory process.
Acute T cell mediated
rejection and it's
important that the transplant
physician determine
the type of rejection
that's occurring.
So acute T-cell mediated
rejection, I'm sure
you've already realized
that's going to be
T-cell related drugs.
So methylprednisolone,
IV high dose pulse,
which means it's given
intermittently in high
doses over several days
followed by an oral
taper. That's the first
line for acute T-cell
mediated rejection.
If that is unsuccessful,
the antithymocyte
globulin will be added.
Or if it's a severe
case to begin with,
the antithymocyte globulin
plus the methylprednisolone.
Alumtuzumab, as we're
going to see, is one
of those drugs that's
infrequently used.
It is an option if
the patient does
not tolerate the
antithymocyte globulin,
but it is difficult to acquire.
Now, antibody-mediated
rejection. What do we
see here? We see our
methylprednisolone again.
This is IV, high-dose
pulse, with an oral
taper. but along with
IVIG, intravenous
immune globulin, and
possibly plasmapheresis.
Rituximab has also been
used, and that would be the
decision of the transplant
physician based on the
individual characteristics.
Pretty simple and
straightforward established
acute allograft rejection.
T-cell, methylprednisolone,
rabbit ATG.
Antibody,
methylprednisolone, IVIG.
Possibly plasmapheresis.
Possibly rituximab.
Easy to remember.
Complications of
immunosuppressive therapy,
immunosuppression, so what do
we need our immune system for
to fight microbial invaders
that cause infection?
Bacterial, fungal, viral,
parasitic. Please remember
that the risk factors
for infection is related
to the intensity and duration
of immunosuppression.
So intensity, we're
thinking about dosing.
And duration, obviously,
is how long will
it have to be given?
Is it given once?
Is it given over a few days?
Is it given continuously,
depending on the half-life of
the drug, over weeks or months?
Now malignancy.
Immunosuppression.
Immunosuppressive
therapy, particularly over
time, can cause cancers,
various cancers. The most
common one seen with
immunosuppressive therapy
is something called
post-transplant
lymphoproliferative disorders.
is lymphoproliferative.
So what is this?
Think Epstein-Barr virus.
Epstein-Barr virus
and Epstein-Barr virus
causes mononucleosis.
You may be familiar with that,
kissing disease.
Epstein-Barr virus
remains latent in B cells.
And T-cell response
is important for
preventing it from
becoming active again.
So what are we doing with our
transplantation
immunosuppressive therapy?
We're suppressing
T-cell activity.
And therefore, Epstein
-Barr virus can become
active and it would cause
proliferation of B-cells.
The PTLD, post-transplant
lymphoproliferative
disorder, is usually caused by
Epstein-Barr virus
that becomes active.
And 90 to 95% of adults
show serologic evidence
of infection. They're
serology positive for Epstein
-Barr virus. It generally
doesn't bother us through
our lifetimes because
we are immunocompetent.
We have good immune systems.
So what are the principal
risk factors for PTLD?
The degree of T
-cell suppression.
So what are we
talking about here?
Intensity and duration.
and the EBV serologic
status of the patient,
positive or negative.
We'll be getting
back to this concept.
Let's begin with ATG. The
rabbit-derived antithymocyte
globulin is the most
frequently used version
by far. So I will be
concentrating on this one.
It's also prepared
in horses, so there's
equine antithymocyte
globulin. But
I will not be talking
about that one.
So where does this come from?
Anti-thymocyte globulin.
Globulin meaning antibodies,
thymocyte meaning
T-cells, and anti-meaning
against, against T-cells.
So thymocytes are
injected into rabbits,
and the rabbits form
antibodies against
the various antigens
on the T-cells.
So because there are
a lot of different
directed antibodies, it's
called polyclonal. There
are lots of different,
the antibodies are
directed against lots
of different antigens.
These IgG antibodies
are isolated then
from the serum of the
rabbits, purified,
and put into a
pharmacologic preparation.
So keep this in mind. This
is a structure activity
relationship, and it will
help explain how this
particular product, ATG, is
a depleting agent. It's a
thymocyte depleting agent.
So here's our mechanism.
And this is an
apparent mechanism,
apparent. Over time,
probably there are other
activities involved. It
appears that ATG acts on
a wide variety of these
T-cell surface antigens.
That will draw the
cytotoxic effect of the
NK cells, the antibody
-related cytotoxicity,
antibody-dependent
cellular cytotoxicity.
Naturally, we have an
acronym for it, as well as
the complement-mediated
cytotoxicity. So cytotoxicity,
these cells are being
killed and depleted.
There are likely
other mechanisms
involved, which
bears repeating.
the antibodies that have
been acquired from the
rabbit serum include
antibodies against all of
these various t-cell antigens
got a half-life of two
to three days it stays
around in the blood for
a week to two weeks,
but the lymphopenia
may persist for up to
a year. It takes that
long for the immune
system to regenerate.
So you can imagine
an allograft is
being placed into
an individual.
there will be a strong
immune response against it so
induction therapy requires
strong immunosuppression
depletion of the peripheral
t-cells in this case
well what about adverse
effects well the fusion
reactions are common
we're putting in all these
foreign proteins,
proteins that have been
developed inside the
rabbit, so rabbit proteins.
Infusion reactions
are flu-like symptoms.
Patients really
feel like they have
the flu. They're
achy, fever, chills,
nausea, and on top
of that, there can
be infusion site
pain, also redness.
Class effects of
immunosuppressants, so infection and
the potential, potential for
infection and the potential
for post-transplant
lymphoproliferative disease.
So this is induction
therapy given
at the time of the transplant.
Antithymocyte
globulin is not used
alone, usually with
methylprednisolone,
and the maintenance therapy
is begun right away.
Now, another infusion
reaction that's been seen is
something called cytokine
release syndrome. So as these
antibodies are being put
in, it can cause a release
of cytokines from the various
cytokine producing immune
cells and this can lead
to serious cardiopulmonary
events so since this is a
known reaction particularly
with the first dose when
the host has uh it's entire
his entire his or her or
their entire complement of
T-cells, the cytokine release
syndrome can be at the
highest level. Later on, as
the T-cells are depleted,
this particular adverse
effect is likely to be
limited. But since we know
about it, we can mitigate
it first of all we don't
give by rapid infusion
ATG is given by slow
infusion over hours secondly
the patient can be pre
-treated by being given
oral glucocorticoid
like prednisone plus
acetaminophen and
possibly an antihistamine,
and that can mitigate
some of the reaction.
Finally, what about pregnancy?
Well, individuals who
may become pregnant are
recommended to use effective
contraception during
and at least three months
following treatment.
Moving now to the T-cell non
-depleting agent.
This is basiliximab.
It is a chimeric monoclonal
antibody that targets the
IL-2 receptor alpha chain.
And we'll see a picture.
And this particular piece
of the protein of the
entire receptor is a
protein that's called CD25.
So, basiliximab is an anti-CD25
chimeric monoclonal antibody.
So, you can picture it here,
label it, draw
your own picture,
I'll make a picture of
IL-2 receptors with the
variable chains attaching
to it, and there it is.
IL-2 receptor alpha chain
is a high-affinity receptor.
Bazilexamab does bind to it
on the surface of T cells.
Here's our alpha chain on
our activated T cell, and
we get, here's basiliximab,
and this will bind here.
So that will block IL
-2 from binding, and
that will cause IL-2
receptor downregulation
and prevent proliferation.
This drug here,
Diclizumab, has not been
on the market for many
years. But this picture
is from when it was on the
market. You can ignore that
as far as I'm concerned.
Induction therapy in
transplant patients with low
risk of acute rejection.
It's been found to be most
effective in this population
of patients, given also
with IV methylprednisolone,
and the maintenance
immunosuppression regimen
is given at the same time.
It's got its
indication for kidney
transplant, but it's
used off-label for
heart, liver, and
lung transplant.
It's given in two doses.
So on the day of
the transplant,
day zero, and four days.
It can also be used
in the treatment
of graft-versus-host disease.
Potential toxicities.
Well, this drug is actually
quite well tolerated,
the two doses only.
hypersensitivity reactions
as you would expect it
is a protein and it is
a protein with foreign
parts on it mousy parts
at the variable component
of the antibody no
cytokine release syndrome
no significant metabolic
drug reactions so it's a nice
option for people with low
risk of acute rejection.
Alemtuzumab is something
called a lymphocyte
depleting agent and it's
also referred to as a
panlymphocyte depleting
agent because it will
deplete all lymphocytes,
all types of lymphocytes,
by binding to the CD52
antigen on the T cell.
I've indicated here that
the drugs are available
only through special
programs, which makes its
availability a bit difficult.
It comes in two forms,
CAMPATH, this is for
transplantation pharmacology,
and Lemptrata, which
is multiple sclerosis.
We will be talking
about alumtuzumab in the
context of transplantation
immunosuppression.
The dosing is different
between the two uses.
Here's a figure to
help you visualize what
we're talking about.
So it binds to the
CD52 receptor, which
is indicated here.
You see the variable portion
there is binding to the CD52.
That induces direct lysis of T
-cells, both
complement, binding,
and antibody-dependent cellular
cytotoxicity with the NK cell.
It may also cause
direct apoptosis.
In any case, it causes
T- and B-cell depletion.
And in turn, causes a profound,
prolonged immunosuppression.
Profound.
So you can imagine.
Because the patient's T and B
cells are being
depleted. Tuzumab
is associated with a
number of serious, life
-threatening, adverse effects,
and has quite a few so
-called black box warnings
about it. The hematologic
effects are what you
would expect from that
profound immunosuppression,
depletion of T and B
cells, lymphopenia,
neutropenia, thrombocytopenia,
pancytopenia, also causes
autoimmune hemolytic anemia
and autoimmune idiopathic
thrombocytopenia.
And these are seen with
the transplantation doses,
serious infections, malignancy,
you would expect that.
and malignant neoplasms
as well as PTLD.
Infusion reactions.
I've indicated here, just
so you get the sense of it,
the multiple sclerosis
treatment, which is
more doses and the patient
can get a treatment
year one and year two as well.
So autoimmune effects,
malignancies, and serious
infusion reactions are
associated with the MS treatment.
Pregnant patients,
patients who could become
pregnant, effective
contraception recommended
during at least three
months after the last
dose. If it's for multiple
sclerosis, they actually
recommend four months
after the last dose.
and glucocorticoids i
put stars on prednisone
and methylprednisolone
there are of course
numerous others but we'll
concentrate on these two
the classic mechanism is
the glucocorticoid which
travels around in the bloodstream
on proteins will diffuse
passively across cellular
membranes into the cells
and bind to the glucocorticoid
receptors, which the
glucocorticoids affect
virtually all cells it gets to.
The glucocorticoid receptor
and steroid complex
move into the nucleus
dimerize and produce
different types of
effects. Transcription or
transactivation we see on
this figure to the right.
Or transrepression by
recruiting other molecules
that lead to repression.
So it is the trans
-repression that is the
anti-inflammatory effects.
Now some anti
-inflammatory effects of
glucocorticoids appear really
quickly within minutes.
And that's likely by an
independent mechanism
that's not involved
with transcription.
We're going to concentrate
on the classic mechanism.
Transrepression will
be inhibiting all these
various functions that
would lead to inflammation.
And also, there's some
activation that goes
on that leads to
inhibition of inflammation.
and adverse effects is related
to uh the insufficiency
of the adrenal glands we
see diabetes and glaucoma
we see osteoporosis growth
retardation skin atrophy
cushingoid appearance this
whole symphony of adverse
effects that occurs with
long-term glucocorticoid use.
You don't need to memorize
this. The point of this
slide is to show you that
glucocorticoids have broad
effects to produce the
anti-inflammatory actions.
the takeaway here in
terms of transplantation
pharmacology is
it inhibits t-cell
proliferation and dampens
the humoral immunity
therapeutic effects
prevention and treatment of
transplant rejection
induction maintenance acute
transplant rejection gbhd
prevention and a myriad of
inflammatory and
autoimmune diseases.
It is really a
mainstay of therapy.
Acute effects are impaired
immunity, naturally,
which increases the risk of
opportunistic infections,
delayed wound healing,
hyperglycemia,
which over time the
patient can actually become
diabetic, type 2 diabetes
increased cholesterol
in the bloodstream salt
retention increased
blood pressure and this
is with the drugs that
have mineralocorticoid
action not all of them do
and mood changes the patients
can feel amazing or they
can be really depressed and
irritated and irritating
uh peptic ulcers gi bleed
peptic ulcers we associate
this with decreased
prostaglandin effects correct and
it's similar here cushingoid
effects and i have the
picture of the uh the
cushingoid appearing individual
in the figure so this round
face They call it a moon
face or moon facies with
this redness in their cheeks.
The buffalo hump at
the back of the neck at
the top of the, just
above the shoulders.
That's called nuchal
fat deposition.
Abdominal weight
gain, but the arms
and legs can become
thin, bruisable.
hair growth acne and over
long periods of time with
these drugs and some people
do have to take them for
years osteoporosis cataracts
and in the children there is
reduced growth rate the
good thing is that when the
drug is removed the child
growth rate usually recovers
dose dependent
dose related adverse
effects so the goal
then for patients who
do have to take them
over time would be
the lowest effective
dose makes nothing
but sense doesn't it
here's our figure
hopefully this will help
you to be able to
visualize all these
various delayed effects,
Cushingoid effects.
I invite you to draw
your own picture. Even
if you don't consider
yourself very good
at drawing, it's still
worth the effort.
In summary,
here's the scheme, the
general approach to
organ transplantation
therapy. Patient preparation,
combination
immunosuppressive therapy,
intensive induction,
maintenance therapy,
which is going to start at
higher doses with the
goal of gradually tapering
down each agent in the
initial triple therapy.
Hopefully even remove
a drug, usually the
glucocorticoid, to a level
that will prevent rejection.
Of course, the patient must
constantly be followed,
and rejection is determined
by biopsy and histology.
High-dose pulse glucocorticoid
therapy, ATG, may be necessary.
The principal approach to
immunosuppressive therapy is
to alter the lymphocyte
function using drugs or
therapeutic antibodies against
the immune system proteins.
There are immunosuppressant
agents to inhibit rejection.
They will also inhibit
aggressive, barren immune
response, thus morbidity and
mortality caused by autoimmune
and chronic inflammatory
disorders. The classes
of drugs used in transplantation
immunosuppression
are the antibodies, the
biologicals, glucocorticoids,
calcineurin inhibitors,
antimetabolites, co-stimulation
blockers, and proliferation
signal inhibitors.
The immunosuppressants share
the common side effects
of increasing susceptibility
to infectious diseases.
Class effects.
And they all share that. Plus
the potential for malignancy
with long-term use related
to dose and duration.
post-transplant
lymphoproliferative
disorder in patients
who are harboring latent
Epstein-Barr virus
in their b-cells.
ATG is the the one that's
used that's used way
more often than the others
is the rabbit version.
Thymocytes they're immunized
with human thymocytes
produce these IgG
antibodies directed against
the T cells. These IgG
antibodies are harvested and
purified, turned into a
pharmaceutical product.
Administration
produces profound
lymphopenia because
of T cell depletion.
ATG, along with other agents,
is used at the time of
transplantation to prevent
early allograft rejection.
It's also used
in glucocorticoid
resistant acute
rejection episodes.
Bazeliximab anti-CD25,
which is the high
affinity alpha a chain
on the IL-2 receptor.
Bazalixamab blocks the IL
-2 receptor preventing IL-2
from binding and therefore that
prevents the IL-2 downstream
action of proliferation
and cytokine production.
has a half-life of
about seven days so
it's given two doses
day zero day four
alimtuzumab is cd52 not 25
on t and b cells resulting
in depletion of both
lines profound prolonged
immunosuppression associated
with serious and fatal infusion
reactions and infections
uh it's not on here but of
course we have to be thinking
about post-transplant
proliferative disorder as
well it is an infrequently
used alternative induction
agent it is also approved
for multiple sclerosis and
b-cell chronic lymphocytic
leukemia fda approvals
for those two uses it is
used off-label for
transplantation immunosuppression
Glucocorticoids are
mainstays for suppressing
acute rejection in
solid organ allografts
and in chronic graft
-versus-host disease.
Numerous dose-related
adverse effects.
And that concludes part one of
our transplantation
pharmacology.